estamos sumando y restando vectores
entonces se nos pregunta cómo es más b
donde el vector a es menos 7 y menos 3
jota y el vector es 15 j aquí están los
vectores entonces el vector a es menos 7
y menos 3 jota y el vector b es uno y
más 5 j entonces bueno
aquí los el término y corresponde a la
primera entrada de la coordenada
entonces a la coordenada x y el término
j corresponde a la segunda entrada de la
coordenada es decir la coordenada y
entonces tenemos ahí como xy jota como
ya vamos a sumar entrada entrada igual
como se sumarían dos coordenadas entrada
entrada aquí también en los vectores
vamos a sumar los términos que tengan y
juntos los términos que tengan jota
juntos entonces bueno menos 7 y más 1 y
eso es igual a menos 6 y menos 6 y
y menos 3 j + 5 j esto es 2 j entonces
la cabeza del vector
además b quedaría más bueno que daría
exactamente aquí quedaría en 6 y
+ 2 j aquí y como puedes ver entonces
aquí terminaría la flecha del vector
b como puedes ver estamos simplemente
deslizando este vector hacia acá
entonces quedaría poniendo el principio
del vector b donde termina el vector
y quedaría aquí ya o también podríamos
hacerlo al revés es sumar b más a
entonces bueno vamos a comprobar la
respuesta
la respuesta es menos 6
+ 2 j ahí está perfecto bueno nos vemos